was to find a scientific way to test
whether there is an extra dimension when
it is a fifth dimension the problem is
imagine if you live on the surface of a
sheet of paper and you can't get off it
how do you know there is such a thing as
off the sheet of paper we cannot come
out of length width and height even
saying that sounds a little crazy right
well the way we approach this problem
was if you have a fifth dimension then
they're supposed to be black holes
called brain world black holes that come
from that dimension and if one of them
enters our world it's going to have a
signature in light it will have a
gravitational lensing signature and we
had to develop a whole mathematical
theory for how you classify that
signature the signature turns out to be
a very elegant prediction a wiggle in
the energy spectrum of light that would
be specific to that kind of black hole
well I think it has to do with the story
of art the story of looking at the night
sky and my high school math teacher I
always wanted to be an artist and as a
kid I drew for many many hours and I
realized that the moment of peace when
you're sketching it felt so good and
would you believe that that same
experience I had when I looked at the
night sky and when my geometry teacher
began telling us about all these
beautiful theorems and so that Eureka
was seeing beauty in places that seem
totally disconnected I would say that
the feelings i got from geometry classes
and the feelings i got when looking at
the night sky and the deep mystery of it
just being what it is i believe that
that connection was a thing that hooked
me I always wanted to be able to have
that type of feeling it's a bit like a
painter right you struggle and it's not
always a nice feeling because you know
that it's going back and forth but at
the end of the day you're creating
something that moves you deep inside
that I believe is the experience that
allowed me to do this for so many years
and not get burnt out with it
growing up in dangriga Belize I really
was in a home with my grandparents they
never went to high school and therefore
when I had to do my homework and all of
these things for the most part I was
left all alone but one thing I know that
was very helpful with being self-taught
mathematics is such a rigorous and in
some ways unforgiving medium that it
allows you to quickly see when you're
going down wrong pads if you make any
logical step you will see the error and
it brings you right back on the straight
and narrow
I I believe that my pad would have been
quite different being forced to teach
yourself you're able to learn things
that are quick for you and things that
are harder for you to digest and in a
sense it allows you to develop the game
plan that is tailored this for your
intellectual orientation that's how i
see it personally
well you know one of the profound
connections for me was actually with
Einstein's theory this is generally
viewed as an exotic area of knowledge
space and time bending you hear about
black holes right and all of this stuff
and you sort of feel well you know these
are some out yonder type individuals
just pursuing in a self-indulgent manner
but when you discover that you have to
use this exact theory in fact it's with
the one with black holes for you to set
up GPS technology that to me is a very
profound connection and it's the kind of
connection that I think interests young
people when they see that deep
mathematics deep ideas in physics
actually can help planes land in bad
weather
I had several role models as a kid and I
will say one of the early ones was
definitely Einstein what I loved about
him is that he was not afraid to go into
the unknown intellectually and in a
sense you know imagine the point is
heading west right he must be afraid of
Iraqis and then they hit desert but he
had the perseverance and the bravery to
be able to go into this type of terrain
and that inspires you as a young person
to not be afraid
well I feel that Matt is a great unifier
it is in astronomy its aesthetic
balances in art and in for in particular
dally was one artist that had a profound
influence on me and if you look at his
crucifixion painting he you see Christ
is actually crucified on a cross that is
an unfolding of a four dimensional
object when or did Dolly learned that it
came from mathematics
I believe you pick things in the world
that's amazing for example here in New
York I would walk them or wrong and
we'll show them the skyscrapers and I
would ask them questions you know if
there's a strong hurricane that comes
here will it tip over because you're
wondering right there tight then what
makes it stand up it's amazing beautiful
trigonometry that's right there in the
structural stability of skyscrapers and
then they'll see the plane flying ahead
so would you like to learn the
principles that govern flight that opens
your eyes you know two worlds that each
one of us scientists are not are
mystified by
you